hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut ich
werde hier gerade schön von der Sonne
geblendet ich befinde mich nämlich
aktuell hier in Kopenhagen ja hinter mir
ist ein Fluss und da hinten ist doch ein
Fluss und ich finde diese Stadt auf
jeden Fall unfassbar schön ich weiß
schon ein paar mal es gibt aber heute
einen bestimmten Grund warum ich noch
hier bin also ich bin heute Nacht mit
dem Nachtzug rüber gefahren und dachte
mir kommen ich verbringen heute auf
jeden Fall den Tag noch hier weil ich
eine besondere Mission habe ich sehe
auch absolut aus wie der größte deutsche
Touri Digger vor allem mit diesem
Rucksack hier naja man musste mich
einfach sagen die Leute in Skandinavien
oder zumindest die Leute die sich für
Burger interessieren die machen das
extrem gut also egal ob in Schweden ob
in Dänemark Finnland es gibt überall
richtig krasse Burger Läden und die von
euch die mich kennen wissen auch dass
ich Burger super gerne esse und ich
dachte mir ich nutze den Tag hier heute
noch um einfach mein Horizont noch ein
bisschen zu erweitern und die krassesten
Burger zu testen das machen wir ich habe
mir drei Spots rausgesucht ich hoffe wir
schaffen das alles zeitlich aber ich bin
ein guter Dinge wir probieren überall
ein Burger und ich glaube es wird
richtig cool den ein oder anderen Laden
kennt man auch schon von irgendwelchen
deutschen food Youtubern ich würde sagen
labern war gar nicht lange wir haben
erst 10:30 Uhr deswegen ich bin ziemlich
früh dran und let's go ich könnte mir
auf jeden Fall schon vorstellen hier zu
leben Problem ist nur es ist Arsch teuer
ich war gerade frühstücken habe für so
ein kleines Brot und einen Kaffee 16 €
bezahlt ja hart aber schauen wir mal wie
teuer die Burger sind ich muss auf jeden
Fall sagen die Leute sind hier extrem
sportlich weil Joggen hier alle rum
fahren Fahrrad schon früh morgens das
ist viel krasser als in Deutschland wir
haben heute übrigens Samstag ne
und die erste Station die ich heute
testen werde nennt sich gesseling
Burgers glaube ich das ist auf jeden
Fall auch so der bekannteste den es hier
gibt haben schon Holle und evanjo schöne
Grüße an dieser Stelle beide getestet
und auch als besten Burger Europas
abgestempelt soweit ich weiß deswegen
ich habe hohe Ansprüche und ich bin
gespannt auf gasaline Burgers das war
früher meine alte Tankstelle
let's go was man hier auf jeden Fall
sagen muss die Menschen sehen unfassbar
attraktiv aus also jeder zweite könnte
Model sein ich habe keine Ahnung warum
das so ist klar ich bin auch hier heute
und ich zähle auch dazu aber wenn die
Burger auch nur ansatzweise so gut
schmecken wie die Menschen aussehen dann
äh ganz gut werden also in Deutschland
gibt's natürlich auch hübsche Leute aber
hier fällt mir das irgendwie auf die
sehen alle gut aus auf die Ladies
natürlich
wow ah geil da ist es ja gasoline Grill
und da kann man auch noch tanken kann
man kann hier echt tanken Alter wie
krass aber der hat glaube ich noch nicht
auf also erst in einer halben Stunde ich
bin echt gespannt Leute wir können uns
mal ganz kurz Rezension angucken das
Dingen hat 4,5 Sterne bei Google was auf
jeden Fall echt gut ist also ist in
Ordnung aber der hat 3252 Bewertung
zurecht einer der besten Burger Europas
bzw top 27 der Welt hier gibt es eine
Weltrangliste von Burger die müssen wir
anschauen authentische amerikanische
Burger in Bio-Qualität zwar etwas
höherpreisiger jedoch gerechtfertigt
durch die gute Fleischqualität sieht auf
jeden Fall alles sehr sehr weit aus ich
gehe einfach mal hin und fragt ob die
schon Cheeseburger haben when do you
open okay
I like to take one Cheeseburger
and water
das muss man auch erstmal schaffen ich
sehe auch aus ey wie so ein kleiner
Junge vom Schulhof auf jeden Fall habe
ich ja gesagt dass ich nur äh
Cheeseburger übernehme weil ich mache
drei Burger in zwei Stunden und ja ich
will dir auch alle aufessen Pommes
lassen wir heute ausnahmsweise mal weg
es geht um die Burger thank you so Leute
ich habe halt nur ein Burger bestellt
aber habe ich ja gesagt so sieht der aus
das war jetzt der allererste Burger den
wir heute gemacht haben so sieht er aus
was haben wir drauf Zwiebeln keine
Tomate und Gurken that's it Single
Partie und eine Soße weiß auch gar nicht
ob Du schlauer mit dem besten Burger
Europas anzufangen aber warum nicht
schmeckt auf jeden Fall nach einer Menge
Butter also als hätten wir den mit
Butter zubereitet so sieht's aus von
innen
ich habe auf jeden Fall schon besser
gegessen der ist schon krass so aber
ich habe es mir noch Bilder vorgestellt
fällt vielleicht auch ein bisschen Salz
was man dazu sagen muss das weiß der
erste Burger und bei mir ist es auch
immer so der erste Burger ist nie so gut
wie der dritte Burger wenn ich drei am
Stück mache alle auf demselben Grill und
so wegen Geschmacks erhoben dies das
kann man vielleicht als kleine
Entschuldigung tun also wenn ich einen
Punkt geben müsste würde ich für den
Burger 8,5 von 10 geben ich habe es ein
bisschen höher eingestuft aber ist ja
trotzdem in Ordnung nur für mich
persönlich ist es nicht der beste Burger
Europas aber wir haben noch ein paar
geile Burger heute deswegen würde ich
sagen keine Zeit verlieren weiter geht's
bye bye ich habe euch glaube ich noch
gar nicht gesagt was ich bezahlt habe
ich habe es gerade selber gar nicht im
Kopf aber ich blende euch jetzt hier mal
ein für Burger also nur für den Burger
so Leute ich habe mir jetzt mal schnell
ein E-Bike gezogen damit geht er zum
nächsten Burgerladen der ist 3 km
entfernt aber ich hoffe es wird sich
lohnen der hatte mich 4,7 Sterne und
vielleicht ist ja noch besser wir werden
sehen das ist ganz witzig ich war hier
vor drei Jahren da gab es überall die
Scooter aber die wurden abgeschafft
passen wohl nicht mehr ins Stadtbild
oder keine Ahnung deswegen fahren wir
jetzt mit dem Fahrrad zu
ich hoffe ihr könnt mich überhaupt
verstehen der nächste Burgerladen den
habe ich bei einem dänischen Foodblogger
gefunden deswegen der muss sich ja
wissen und ich hoffe einfach dass wir
noch wilder und ich kann mal eine 9,5
oder so vergeben wir werden sehen Leute
bis gleich Leute in dieser Bar hier
hinter mir war ich übrigens mit meinen
Freunden immer als wir hier waren das
ist echt eine coole Bar also kann ich
empfehlen aloha Bar check das mal ab
vielleicht frage ich Sie auch einfach ob
die mich mit einem Düsenjäger zum
Burgerladen bringen ja was machen wir
hier
ups ich weiß nicht gibt sie eigentlich
auch in Deutschland die sind übelst nice
die Fahrräder ich muss jetzt irgendwo da
runter hier in die Richtung
so Leute Fahrradtour ist zu Ende ich
habe mich acht Mal verfahren aber ich
bin jetzt da hier bei Patties glaube ich
zumindest ja hier muss das jetzt
irgendwo sein das ist ja ganz versteckt
okay ich habe es glaube ich
also das gibt auf jeden Fall alles hier
ich nehme auf jeden Fall wieder ein
Cheeseburger okay also es war auf jeden
Fall voll versteckt hey
one Cheeseburger please
and the water
[Musik]
also ich habe bestellt ich bin mal
gespannt wie schnell das fertig ist weil
ich muss auch irgendwie gleich mein Zug
bekommen aber es ist tatsächlich nur die
dänischen Boys da hinten hatten auf
jeden Fall auch Bock auf dem Burger und
wenn die da schon hin in die
Einheimischen muss das ja gut sein ne
ach so Leute noch als kleine Info der
Burger da hat ungerechte 9,95 € gekostet
also geht auf jeden Fall halbwegs klar
ähnlich wie in Deutschland vielleicht
minimal teurer aber wir sind halt auch
in einem deutlich teuren Land
hey Wechsel thank you bye bye so Leute
ich habe jetzt auf jeden Fall 20 Minuten
auf dem Burger gewartet schon ein
bisschen aber ist noch in Ordnung die
dachte jetzt hier die dänischen Jungs
sind meine Kollegen also mein Burger war
neben dir oder mit deren Burgern
zusammen fertig und dann meinten die so
auf Dänisch glaube ich dass sie gar
keinen Alex kennt lOL na ja jetzt muss
ich erstmal probieren irgendwo hier so
Leute ich bin jetzt wieder am Fluss das
da ist übrigens so ein Sprungbrett also
da so ein da kann man auf jeden Fall von
ins Wasser springen und die da falls ihr
die sehen könnt waren gerade auch
einfach schwimmen das ist ja irgendwie
hier so relativ normal bei 10 Grad oder
wie viel haben wir ich glaube 12 Grad
schwimmen zu gehen naja ich bin hier im
Burger zu essen nicht um schwimmen zu
gehen und wir testen jetzt den letzten
für heute weil im dritten schaffe ich
nicht ich musste mich zum Zug sonst bin
ich erst nach Mitternacht heute zu Hause
und das das geht nicht also ich habe
noch ein echt weiten Weg von mir aber
ich muss dazu sagen ich habe noch gar
nicht Rezensionen vorgelesen also fertig
hat ja 4,7 Sterne und wir haben hier ein
paar Rezensionen leider nur 115
Rezension nicht so viel wie bei dem
anderen Laden aber sehr leckerer
Chickenburger okay den habe ich nicht
bestellt die Rezension ist ganz gut
einer der besten Burger die ich je hatte
vielleicht das beste nostalgie ist
harter Wettbewerb ach so ist
wahrscheinlich Übersetzung Pommes sind
großartig aber mit zu viel Salz Pommes
habe ich nicht bestellt naja gut ich
muss sagen auch der Burger hier sieht
unfassbar geil aus ich muss jetzt
einfach mal probieren Leute ne
dann schauen wir mal
der ist ja das habe ich denn hier bei
LoL
Pommes ist doch dabei doch gar nicht
bestellt ach so ich habe wahrscheinlich
das Lunch Menü bekommen da waren auch
Pommes bei okay
schon lecker okay jetzt ähm machen wir
uns einen Burger gebt euch mal das Leute
also das bannen überzeugt mich schon mal
Tomate fehlt wieder aber man muss dazu
sagen dass es wohl normal in
Skandinavien auf Burgern ist fast nie
eine Tomate drauf also auf klassischen
Cheeseburger in Deutschland ja schon von
Gurken auf Burger bin ich nicht so der
Fan UPS nicht wegbringen aber wir
probieren jetzt einfach mal ich bin
gespannt ey das sieht schon irgendwie
noch geiler aus als der eben
der ist krank Alter check das aus Leute
ein unfassbar guter Burger hier stimmt
eigentlich fast alles Brötchen ist geil
vielleicht ist geil Zwiebeln lecker so
gut gut gewürzt auf jeden Fall besser
als der eben boah ich habe ja schon
wirklich sehr sehr viele Burger gegessen
den besten meiner Meinung nach in
Stockholm bei Barrys aber der macht dem
schon gute Konferenz also hier muss ich
auf jeden Fall deutlich über 9 Punkte
für geben ich glaube das ist eine solide
9,5 Geisteskranker Bürger
ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll
super Ding und Leute ich muss mich
beeilen mein Zug kommt die Möbel will
auch was du kriegst nichts mehr nach
noch eine knackige Pommes dazu
also hierfür hat sich Kopenhagen auf
jeden Fall gelohnt
so Leute damit verabschiede ich mich aus
Kopenhagen ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen lasst mir super gerne Daumen
nach oben da und abonniert den Kanal ich
habe echt jetzt eine riesige halbe
Europa Tour gemacht für vier coole
Videos die kommen werden würde mich auf
jeden Fall super drüber freuen ganz eben
nur empfehlen Fahrt nach Kopenhagen paar
Burger essen oder generell die Stadt
anschauen und ich freue mich jetzt auf
zu Hause weil ich hatte echt wenig
Schlaf die letzten Tage und ja Leute wir
sehen uns haut rein ciao